[Musique]
bienvenue dans envies de lecture de
l'appel wolf
comment ça va vite et ça va trop bien
patrice et vous très bien très bien et
nous avons comme premier invité roland
d'ado bonjour bonjour bonjour alors je
dirais qu'il a le sourire pétillant le
verbe haut est beau le look et le bouc
nostalgiques des socialistes des années
80 voici donc roland d'ado écrivains
romanciers poètes sur tout homme
politique aussi puisque vous allaitez
mère de lui en cours de 1983 à 2002 et
président de saint quentin en yvelines
de 1989 à 1998 et vous publié aux
éditions et le miroir amnésique c'est un
livre dans lequel vous revenez sur votre
parcours d'homme sur ce cheminement
d'engagement politique et poétique sur
ce chemin long et compliqué je vais
citer quand je regarde dans le miroir
amnésie qui sont un de ma vie est un ver
tiré d'un poème de gilles beaudry qui
s'appelle la plénitude des heures
heureuses
alors va revenir évidemment sur ce livre
sur votre parcours
mais il ya peut-être un mot qui résume
votre action votre parcours à la fois
poétique et politique c'est celui
d'engagement est-ce que vous d'eric
votre vie a été une vie d'engagement
ronan nadeau et d'engagement à quoi
engagement à vivre ni à vivre avec les
autres à vivre
on est dans les autres à vivre plusieurs
d'accord possible avec mon enfance et
les valeurs que j'ai reçu et que j'ai
construite peu à peu
et bienfaitrice cité gilles beaudry qui
est moine et poète et qui vous a permis
d'utiliser un dévers sévères comme titre
de votre livre alors vous êtes un homme
est un militant de gauche et même si vos
liens avec l'église ont parfois été
distendus
eh bien ils sont restés très fort vous
parlez beaucoup de prêtres de croyants
dans votre livre vous avez leur avaient
toujours adresser des des signes alors
est ce que vous vous reconnaissez dans
le courant de la gauche catholique et
quelle est l'importance de la religion
dans votre vie alors d'abord moi je suis
né le rhin et lieu qu'aujourd'hui on
appellerait quart monde
à l'époque le mot n'existait pas et dans
une famille qui était anti religieuse en
cléricalo possible mon père était
anarchiste et par exemple lorsque la
communion très tardivement il n'est pas
venu déjeuner à la maison pour nous
montrer sa désapprobation
donc c'est pour vous dire que ça n'est
pas tombée du ciel
cegedim ensuite j'ai été pendant très
longtemps et je le demeure d'ailleurs
conti clérical au sens anti
institutionnelle
le rapport était plutôt un rapport
d'ordre spirituel qu'un rapport d'ordre
organisationnel et puis j'ai quand même
toujours eu en moi malgré 40 ans
d'absence à l'église pendant laquelle
absence pendant laquelle j'ai comme on
dit vulgairement mais de façon assez
imagé bouffer du curé
j'ai été très ami avec beaucoup de
prêtres et puis voilà ça m'est retombé
dessus ou plutôt ses revenus vous savez
c'est comme ces fleurs ses rivières que
don qui ont ce qu'on appelle des
résurgences c'est à dire d'un seul coup
le courant d'eau disparaît dans la terre
on ne sait pas très bien pourquoi est il
réapparaît un autre endroit souvent
inattendues
qui n'est pas dans la ligne normale en
fin de concours anormal de l'écoulement
de l'eau il sort d'un autre côté c'est
un peu ce qui m'est arrivé est mais il
est vrai que j'ai toujours eue on
associe spirituelle qui a occupé
beaucoup de ma vie et qui m'occupe
aujourd'hui terriblement qui a fait
beaucoup pour la réconciliation
justement d'éclat tiré de la gauche
c'est quelqu'un vous avez beaucoup
côtoyé que vous avez avec thil dont vous
étiez la miss était michel rocard et bis
avant car il voulait faire des yvelines
d'ailleurs une terre de mission pour le
pour le pour le parti socialiste
moi je connais des jeunes enfants 68
c'est après jésus-christ oui avec le ps
eut et puis après vous allez dès
ressemble au ps etc
elle avait été élue députée en 1969 dans
les yvelines en battant un grand
personnage de coup de vieux rideaux
liste qui maurice couve de murville et
quand je les ai connus mais michel lui
et de d'origine protestante elle c'est
pas là et moi j'étais plutôt un marginal
enlever le monde catholique
j'étais un militant laïque dont dans le
monde catholique donc c'était compliqué
mais c'était une forme une forme de
réconciliation entre ce qu'ils ont et
apparaître comme des choses antagonistes
de la même façon qu'en politique michel
a essayé de réconcilier et la loi du
marché et le socialisme mais c'est ce
qui m'a beaucoup séduit chez ses tables
en dehors de son charisme évidemment je
dirais
que vous apparteniez à la deuxième
gauche le deuxième rouge
non je sais de cette formule n'a jamais
beaucoup apprécié la dichotomie de la
même façon que j'ai pas du tout apprécié
l'antagonisme entre mitterrand et rocard
dont j'ai suivi quelques conséquences
inattendues
il faudra continuer cette histoire
incroyable c'est à dire que quand
mitterrand on apprend la mort de
mitterrand rocard vous demande de faire
un article mais un article incendiaire
c'est un vétéran disant que c'est l'amie
des truands l état vous ne le faites pas
et ça vous a fâché il vous a plus
reparlé
alors je me souviens en tout cas de la
soirée ils étaient venus dîner à
guyancourt et mitterrand a été témoin et
mon regard s'est livré bien qu'il soit
qu'il fait discret ces livres et d'un
coup mais de façon assourdissante à une
diatribe contre françois mitterrand
kim a suffoqué et à la fin il me dit
écoute roland puisque tu as un beau brin
de plume
tu me prépares tout ce que je viens de
te dire et il en a raconté j'en étais on
va dire plus que baba jan sur le
cul c'est je ne savais plus comment
comment faire il va t'y vas tu vas tu va
rédiger le papier tu me l'envoie à
l'époque il y avait pas de leva
l'internet
tout me l'envoie en fax et puis je le
valide et il sera publié dans la presse
notamment dans le monde et c est moi
j'étais tellement suffoquer je savais
bien qu'il y avait entre les deux et
difficultés mais il y avait de la haine
il y avait là on a appelé l'ex comme s
il y avait de la haine sur toute la puis
alors il s'était quand même le chat et
la souris ou un chat très intelligent
une souris très intelligente mais une
souris
du coup j'en ai pas dormi pendant 4
jours
je n'ai pas fait le papil je me suis
essayé ça ne passait pas et je suis
quelqu'un d'autre qui l'a fait justement
de aussi de vos mandats vous avez été
élu maire de billancourt la ville était
détenu par les communistes
alors vous le dites a à demi mots mais
on a l'impression que la campagne a été
assez violente quel souvenir en gardez
vous ah ça c'est une histoire difficile
compliqué en plus je viens de perdre
deux camarades amis communistes car
c'est la cour qui était maire de la
verrière et il ya quelques jours bernard
hugo il était maire de trappes et les
deux ont été mes vice présidents
lorsque j'étais président de saint
quentin en yvelines mais c'était deux
personnes avec lesquelles j'avais
d'excellentes relations et bien que au
départ nos rapports fut sont extrêmement
tendues nous sommes le sur la fin de
notre vie mais moi aussi des gens jouent
dans cette période
redevenu très amis mais guyancourt et
est un cas particulier c'était une ville
qui c'était un village
lorsque je suis arrivé un il comptait à
fin 2000 habitants avec les hameaux
aujourd'hui ces trente mille habitants
prendre et donc la ville avait été
conquise à la libération par un artisan
communiste assez assez intéressant
j'avais à faire malheureusement à on va
dire des des communistes locaux alors
que j'étais ami avec d'autres communiste
qui n'avait pas encore reçu télégramme
annonçant la mort de staline
alors que nous étions dans des années 70
et qui est crispée sur un sur une forme
de stalinisme archaïque épouvantable
sectaire et ils ont pas aimé que je
gagne les primaires donc des moments de
tension très fort a tellement d'ailleurs
que je me suis fait casser la gueule et
que j'ai encore aujourd'hui le nez est
cassé à l'intérieur parce qu'il n'a pas
été réparée à temps
entre autres choses donc ça a été des
moments très très très difficile bilan
totalement peut aussi de votre livre le
miroir amnésique la poésie très présente
dans ce livre dans votre style dont les
extraits qui gèle ouvrages dont vos
préférences
comment est née la poésie cet amour de
la poésie chez vous et est peut-être une
question un peu vaste qu'est ce que
c'est la poésie avant bien le livre est
volontairement à la demande de mon
éditeur qui lance une nouvelle
collection avec trois ouvrages dont le
mien c'est son idée c'est la poésie
comme elsa c'est les titres de la
collection et c'est l'idée de faire une
espèce de d'autobiographie mais qui soit
venu uniquement sous l'angle au pot
éthique donc la partie politique de nous
avons parlé est à la limite secondaire
ce que je raconte y compris les ce que
je viens de raconter dans la sphère de
l'usfa michel rocard s'était lié à
l'écriture
mais si j'avais parlé politique j'aurais
parlé de bien d'autres choses
alors qu'apple en poésie ses aînés de la
fréquentation des poètes
c'est à dire que j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir d'excellents prof au collège qui
m'ont fait lire des poètes
ça a déclenché en moi l'envié d'écrire
j'avais 12-13 ans et c'est ça en
quatrième et puis je me suis mis à
écrire de plus en plus un en troisième
et en seconde j'ai rencontré entre
autres absolument formidable qui m'a
fait rencontrer un des fondateurs du
surréalisme si le support qui est devenu
un grand ami qu'est devenu mon papa en
caux esi après quoi j'ai rencontré
évidemment andré breton et quelques
autres et j'aime j'aime fonder une revue
n'étant adolescent j'ai déjà 14 en
seconde comme normal de versailles et
avec quelques amis dont certains
d'ailleurs sont venus là en peintre
célèbre l otan musicien célèbre a pu
mourir voilà seul entrer là dedans j'ai
été publié de très vite dans des revues
mon premier livre est sorti j'avais 19
ans c'était de la prose poétique et puis
voilà
c'est et puis je dois dire puisque le
temps nous est compté que la politique
j'y ai été entraînés en vol entièrement
et elles incluent prise comme un loisir
mais ça ne va dire qu'ils occupent et ma
vie professionnelle et la poésie a été
pour moi ce qui m'a sauvée de la dureté
de la violence du monde politique et en
même temps la réconcilier avec ma vie
spirituelle retrouvera délire dans votre
style dans votre façon d'écrire
cette poésie dans le miroir amnésique
d'ailleurs vous êtes un thuya il y en a
d'autres il y as encore il ya césaire
yahia il ya quelques responsables
politiques aussi qui sont aussi des
dépôts est ce que je vous propose c'est
que ben content quand les temps seront
meilleurs sanitairement qu'on se
retrouve sur ce plateau qui peut qu'on
continue cette conversation
pour l'instant je renvoie votre livre le
miroir amnésique aux éditions henry la
poésie comme elle va merci beaucoup
rouleau nadeau
[Musique]